how deep does the Demon Slayer Iceberg
go what is the origin of demons what's
the deal with hinosuke's Father what
place is censored what parts of Demon
Slayer how dark do demon Sarah theories
get and much more is dealt with in this
video as we move from the more commonly
known and visible aspects of Demon
Slayer to the less commonly known and
darker aspects of it so make sure to
stay tuned for that since the further
you get the deeper you get in your Demon
Slayer knowledge now let's make an
agreement here if you learn something
new in this video then like and
subscribe to the channel That is my one
and only request and without further Ado
let's dive in so for layer 1 the most
visible layer of the iceberg we got the
anime which began airing in 2019 so far
the anime that focuses on demonstrator
tanjiro and his demon sister nezuko has
had three seasons season one included
his demonstrator training Arc and his
fight against lower Moon 5 rui season 2
included the mugench train Arc and his
fight against buffed up lower Moon 1 and
move and season 3 included the
Entertainment District Arc and his fight
against upper Moon six daki and gyutaro
season 4 called The swordsmith Village
Arc is set to release April 2023 and
trailers have revealed that the Miss
pillar and the love pillar will be
highlighted in this one and with that
let's go deeper to layer 2. now this
layer will deal with manga stuff in
manga mystery so there will be spoilers
I mean what do you expect in a video
That's supposed to go deep with the
knowledge I've seen some Iceberg videos
actually put manga reveals way down in
the lower layers of an iceberg but that
makes no sense to me since if people
just had to read the Manga to figure it
out it's not that deep so we'll be
covering manga stuff in this one so that
even manga fans can learn something as
they move deeper down the anime
demonstrator is based on the Demon
Slayer manga which ran in weakly Shonen
jump from February 15 2016 to May 18
2020. so for over four years the manga
was created by
and is classified as simultaneously
being an adventure Dark Fantasy and
martial arts Story the original manga
consists of 23 volumes and 205 chapters
now let's get into some of the biggest
mysteries revealed in the manga musan
was the first demon and he was turned
into a demon by a doctor living in the
hayen period notably the hayen period
ran from the year 794 to 1185. muzan was
sick and frail since he was in the womb
and he was going to die before he turned
20. the doctor worked hard to give him a
little longer to live but muzan was mad
about his worsting condition so in a fit
of rage he took the doctor's life only
after did he realize that the doctor's
medicine was having an effect he gained
Incredible strength but could no longer
be exposed to sunlight he also started
to Crave human flesh and started to eat
people ever since he became a demon he
desired a body that would not die in the
sun all he knew was that the doctor used
blue spider lilies in his experiment but
since he took his life muzon couldn't
ask him to continue his race search or
where he found the blue spider lilies
muzon continued to search for these
flowers but never succeeded in finding
them notably the blue Spider Lily does
not exist in real life and in the series
it was revealed in the Final Chapter
that the flower only blooms during the
day two or three days a year which is
why muzon could never find it since he
could only search for it at night
speaking of musan in his wish to be able
to survive in the sun though nezuko ends
up becoming immune to the sun muzon
assumes that he can become immune to the
sun too if he consumes nezuko however he
never gets to consume her because a she
has turned back to human with medicine
and B the demonstrator core succeeds in
beating muzon then we get the very crazy
Twist of Tantra briefly becoming the
next Demon King yes muzan gives his
power to tanjiro in the hopes that he
will take his place as the perfect being
and since nezuko could gain immunity to
the sun muzon rightly predicts that
Demon King tanjiro will be able to gain
an immunity to it as well tendro becomes
the perfect demon that moves on longed
for but the power of the medicine and
friendship turns him back to normal the
consequences of the final battle are
brutal though our protagonist Tundra has
lost the use of an arm and an eye while
gyu suned me in the long retired tengen
are the only hasha to survive the final
battle even satomi's little brother
genya doesn't make it through the final
battles the final chapter of demon sir
fast forwards to modern day Tokyo we see
some ancestors and some reincarnations
the general rule is that the characters
who survived the battle with the demons
left descendants while the characters
that died fighting the demons got
reincarnated so that they could live out
a happier life through the descendants
it's made clear that Tundra ended up
with Kano and zenitsu ended up with
nezuko when this chapter initially
dropped some of the fandom even
questioned if it was zenithal who ended
up together or if it was their
descendants but to me it was pretty
obvious from the beginning it was that's
going zenitsu and will get clarification
later as well from the mangaka but
notably we even see a descendant of
inosuke's but will have to wait until
lower in the ice Brooke to see who he
ended up with yorichi the sun breather
who beat and traumatized muzon is
another mysterious figure some guessed
that he was tanja's Dad or at least an
ancestor at first but as is revealed in
the manga he was actually upper Moon
one's brother he created the original
and strongest breath style Sun breathing
and then helped other demon Sayers come
up with the inferior offshoots that we
know today like water and Flame
breathing he lost his wife and child to
demon so he didn't have any descendants
as far as we know however he did save a
descendant of tanjiros a man called
sumioshi kamado sumiyoshi passed down
yorichi's earrings and Sun breathing
style through the dance of the fire god
to Future Generations until they reached
tanjiro the man who would go on to
finally beat muzon of course with help
an interesting detail that's easy to
miss in your first read-through is that
zaitsu Senpai kaigaku is also the orphan
who betrayed yomey and other orphans to
a demon he would go on to betray his
insane to Sensei to become a demon
himself their Sensei takes his own life
life because of this this leads to one
of the most epic fights in the series
where zenitsu seeking to avenge his
Sensei takes on kaigaku who's become the
new upper Moon 6. Not only does zenitsu
beat an upper moon on his own we even
find out that he created his own epic
form of Thunder breathing called seventh
form honoi kazuchi nokami AKA flaming
Thunder God wow what an epic name then
there's the mystery of inosuke's father
and how his father was actually upper
Moon 2 Doma well at least in a sense
when Doma first signed nosuke's mom she
was only 17 or 18 and had already given
birth to baby nosuke it's revealed that
her husband AKA nosuke's biological
father beat her every day and her
mother-in-law bullied her too as a
result she ran away and joined doma's
cult called Paradise Faith she had even
gone blind in one eye because of the
beatings when she found out that
inosuke's new demon stepfather was
eating his other followers she tried to
escape with baby nosuke she dropped
inosuke from a cliff so he could Escape
while her life was taken by dolma baby
nosuke went on to survive alive and was
raised by boars he'd go on to create his
own breathing style Beast breathing
akasa upper Moon 3 and the guy that took
our beloved flame hashra from us is
actually a good guy now good guy might
not be the right word for him and it
might be a bit extreme but man does his
backstory make you look at him
differently he became a criminal because
he was stealing medicine for his sick
father he fell in love with a girl and
the Rival Dojo killed her and her father
who was akasa's Mentor so he took them
all down and didn't care about living
anymore when muzon found him even after
losing his memories and becoming a demon
akasa refused to eat women who are
especially nutritious and would have
made him stronger it's even mentioned
that dolma might have not surpassed him
if akasa ate women as well but his
principles even as a demon were stronger
than his desire to just well get
stronger now I'm sure there were
interesting details or mysteries on the
manga that I've left out but those are
some of the bigger Mysteries and
surprises that manga readers would be
aware of if I left some big stuff out in
your opinion let me know in the comments
and it may make it an updated version of
this video down the line so make sure
you're subscribed for when that comes
out now it's time for layer three we're
getting deeper down and you could have
watched all the episodes and read all
205 chapters and still not know this
stuff first let's start with a
considerable Mistake by the mangaka in
the original release of chapter 204
Tundra who has lost the use of one arm
is shown cleaning with both arms and
eating with both arms on the final page
this was corrected in the 23rd and final
volume of the demonstrom manga series
The mangaka apologized for this error to
the fans in the weekly author's note in
Shonen jump but I don't think any of us
hold it against her especially
considering the very busy schedule for
mangaka who have to publish chapters
weekly on the topic of the mangaka they
maintain anonymity in public and
koyoharu gotoge is in actuality a pen
name the mangaka uses an alligator with
glasses as their Avatar when making
announcements about their series and
although many people at least in my
comment section seem to think koyoharu
gotoge is a man a weekly Shonen Jump
employee disclosed that the mangaka is a
woman which is why you'll hear me saying
she in Prior demonstrate videos on this
channel and probably later in this video
as well and by the way she joins a
stacked lineup of female mangaka who
created amazing works and some of my
favorites like Inuyasha Fullmetal
Alchemist honey and clover Marsh comes
in like a lion and many more koyoharu
has commented that she Drew inspiration
from multiple other manga like Gintama
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure Naruto and
leech this 33 year old award-winning
mangaka also became the first one Gaga
to be included in Time magazine's annual
list of the 100 most influential people
in 2021 because of the popularity of
Demon Slayer if you want rewind that
because it's huge and as I mentioned
before we find out who inosuke ended up
with in the bonus material that was
revealed after the final chapter in the
23rd volume although you might have
predicted it already it was in fact Ali
we're told that the owl
that we saw in the Final Chapter is
their great grandchild and we even get a
super cute bonus panel of inosuke with
his boar mask gifting owie nuts and
acorns to her Delight it is definitely
the least focused on romantic
relationship of the main three but if
you want a detailed breakdown of it and
all the earlier clues that they'd end up
together you can check out my video on
enoskin aoi's relationship explained
Link in the description these bonus
pages also made the ending much more
satisfying in my opinion since the
original ending did feel rushed and many
fans have commented on this in fact it
seems like there was a reason for this
since multiple articles have claimed
that koyoharu rushed the ending part
because of family issues specifically
due to a situation with their parents in
addition to the bonus ending in the
final manga volume there are also
interesting extra pages between chapters
that reveal stuff about the Demon Slayer
world that you wouldn't otherwise know
since they aren't mentioned in the main
story for instance in one of these Pages
we find out why mitsuri's uniform is
more revealing than that option Nobles
for example the demonstrator uniform
Taylor called masal maida designed all
the female uniforms to be similarly
revealing so it's not surprising that
he's been nicknamed the four-eyed creep
in the series however shinobu burned her
uniform and gave oil in matches so that
aoi and kanal could burn theirs too this
explains why they don't have uniforms
like mitsuris mitsuri ultimately
continued to wear hers as is despite
being initially embarrassed about it
also if you didn't know her green socks
were a gift from her true love iguro the
snake hashiram and these extra pages can
also deliver very random information
indeed like in one case we're told that
Tundra's ancestor's wife suyako slept
like crazy and would end up falling
asleep on the roadside multiple times
causing her husband Sumi Yoshi to worry
if she's alright there are also two fan
books that have yet to be translated
into English I can't wait until they are
released though since within them we
have gems like information about how
xenesu's kasugai Crow is the only
Sparrow to appear here in the series and
passed the kasugi test it is the only
one that can't talk its family was
killed by demons so I wanted to help
them too yes even Zain to Sparrow has a
meaningful backstory although nickname
chuntaro we're told his name is actually
ukogi in the complete volumes box set
release not only do you get a cool
Demon's air box with the complete 23
volumes showcasing the tundra vs muzon
final battle on one side but they also
throw in a poster which has tanjoinosuke
zanitsu Kano and gyu holding their
swords on one side and tanjon let's go
on the reverse side it also comes with a
short bonus demonstrator core Special
Report it doesn't have much except some
character breakdown some early sketches
and some bonus trivia facts like that
zenitsu love sweets and expensive foods
like eels so he would have been fat if
he wasn't a swordsman layer 4 Demon's
air is bigger than you ever could have
imagined it is currently the 9th
best-selling manga of all time in
climbing this is insane for a number of
reasons demon series started in 2016 and
the second most recent one after it in
the top 10 namely Naruto started in 1999
meaning all the other ones had 17 years
or in most cases a lot more to grow
their sales another notable detail is
that within the top 10 demonster has the
least volumes to sell it only has 23
while half of the top 10 have 100
volumes or more and one namely golgo 13
has 205. put another way despite how
relatively new Demon's air is it has
almost the most average sales per volume
at 6.52 million beating out one piece
and Naruto by this metric in the top 10
only the iconic OG battle shown in
Dragon Ball has a higher average sales
per volume at 8.33 million and it came
out 32 years before Demon Slayer Demon
Slayer broke record after record
articles came out about demonster alone
outselling the entire Comics industry in
2020. in 2019 oricon had demonstrator
number one at their yearly manga sales
rank talking at over 12 million copies
sold then get this in 2020 they came in
first again but this time wait for it
demonsters sold over 82 million copies
second place Kingdom only sold about 8.2
million AKA about 10 times less and
don't get me wrong 8.2 million is a lot
but demon says numbers just dwarfed
everything else beyond belief 2021 was
another great year for manga
surprisingly Demon Slayer wasn't first
but it came close first place was
Jujutsu Kaizen with about 31 million
then Demon Slayer with about 29.5
million and then Tokyo Revengers with
almost 25 million still an amazing year
for Demon's hair and crazy the thing
that just two years prior all three of
these manga would have been more than
doubled what first place got so it seems
that the insanity of Demon Slayer
boosted manga sales in general at least
temporarily perhaps not surprisingly
since the demon Sarah manga has been
finished for a while demonstrator didn't
make the top 5 best-selling series of of
2022 while Jiu Jitsu Kaizen Tokyo
Revengers spyex family one piece and my
hero Academia did however Jutsu kaizen's
top spot of 12.3 million is a far cry
from Demon's Air's record of 82 million
in a year and even a lot less than its
own sales a year prior it goes to show
how insanely popular demon Sarah was in
2020 and it wasn't just the manga that
broke records the demonstrate movie
became the number one highest grossing
movie of all time in the Japanese box
office comfortably beating out insanely
popular movies like Spirited Away
Titanic Frozen and your name it's not
just the fact that an anime movie became
number one since that happened before
obviously was Spirited Away but the fact
that a movie based on a Shonen anime
series hit number one is unheard of now
the demonstrator has gotten the ball
rolling one Piece Film red also recently
broke into the top 10. but before that
you wouldn't see movies for shown an
anime series anywhere close to this high
up the demonstrator opening theme song
even closed out the 2020 Tokyo Olympics
the song peaked at number two on
Billboard Japan's Hot 100 rankings
showing how vastly popular it was in
Japan but it's even more awesome that it
was performed on the world stage like
that showing how demon Sarah was
captivating the entire world one way or
another and since we're on popularity
here let me just go over the character
popularity polls of this insanely
popular series in other words let's see
who was the most popular of the most
popular in the first popularity poll the
top 10 most popular were from first
attempt tanjira zaitsu nazukogo inosuke
shinobu rengoku kanal the mangaka
herself and makomo and I'm just gonna
guess that makomo won't make it to the
second popularity poll in the second
popularity poll which was released in
2020 the list went like this zenitsu
first gyu second tokito the Mist hashira
third followed by tanjoshinobu inosuke
Ren Goku iguro sanami and kanal the last
one was done after the series was
completed so it gives you a good sense
of how the fanbase felt after the finale
I totally get zaitsu being first after
his epic fight with upper Moon kaigaku
and everything but I must admit I'm
pretty surprised Tundra dropped all the
way to Fourth Place layer five now let's
get into the world of Demon's air
spin-offs one spin-off you may have seen
clips on YouTube from is Junior High and
High School kimetsu Academy Story it's a
spin-off mini series of anime shorts set
in the kimetsu academy Universe which is
itself a spin-off Universe in the modern
world based off characters in Demon
Slayer there's also a manga taking place
in this universe called kimetsu Gakuen
the manga started in 2021 and it's
ongoing its genre is classified as
comedy school life and spin-off as you
may imagine they find creative roles for
the different characters to fill in the
modern world even if they were hashing
our demons in the original manga in
junior high you'll find people like
Central rengoku and nezuko in senior
high you'll find tanjiro Zain suindosuke
Nobu and more most of the hashira are
staff Kyu is a PE AKA physical education
teacher and he's known in the school as
the man who never Smiles tangent is the
art teacher yomey is the Civics teacher
and first-year homeroom teacher sonami
is the math teacher Kanai is the biology
teacher and flower arrangement Club
advisor snake hashira obanai iguro is
the chemistry teacher and you may get a
kick out of sakonji urokodaki being the
School Janitor in love hashira mitsuri's
case she's already graduated and
attending an art university nearby muzon
is an evil politician trying to take
over Japan a permanent one kokushibo is
musan secretary while upper Moon 2 Doma
is a scam artist but not all demons are
Super Evil in this world kyogai the drum
demon is a music teacher in the school
even gutero and ume AKA daki make an
appearance they are the greatest
delinquent siblings of the academy and
frequently cause trouble there was also
a demon Sarah video game called The
hinokami Chronicles I actually played it
when it came out and the fun thing is
you can actually choose to play as
characters from The kimetsu Academy
Universe in the game the game is a third
person action Arena fighter allowing the
two players to fight on a battlefield
think Smash Bros or Dragon Ball Z
Budokai games demonstrator light novels
have also been released like the flower
of Happiness One Wing butterfly and
signs from the wind these three light
novels expand on the Demon Slayer story
covering stuff like when shinobu and her
sister first came to beg yomey to take
them on as demonstrate apprentices and
when the hashira were given the
unorthodox request of trying to make the
water husher a smile the flower of
happiness has already been officially
released in English while the one wing
butterfly is set to release in February
28 2023 and signs from the wind is set
to release on June 27 2023. you can
pre-order them now on Amazon Plus if you
like it in Goku and Gio you're in luck
because there is a manga volume called
Demon's hair stories of water and Flame
that you can purchase notably this
spin-off wasn't done by demonstrate
Creator koyoharu gotoge in the same way
that the official series was although
gotoge is credited for the original
concept on the cover ryoji hiran channel
is credited for the story and art on the
Amazon side itself gotoge is credited as
draft writer this might be how we get
future demon Sarah manga as well since
it seems like gotoge will not be
returning to the series rather gotogay
said she'd be working on a science
fiction romantic comedy next but I'm
sure we're all on the same page and
hoping the mangaka changes her mind and
comes back to handle future Demon Slayer
projects this is actually looking more
possible recently since after the
statements made about the science
fiction romantic comedy more recent
articles have come out reporting that
gotokee still hasn't decided on or
started any next work but back to the
rengoku and giyumanga spin-offs gyu's
story follows him as he and shinobu help
a girl whose father has become a demon
this takes place after he initially
saves tanjiro and Spares nazuko they
saved the girl before her demon father
can take her life and try to encourage
her to live on even though it feels like
she's lost everything the fights aren't
really the focus here but if you like
you and shinobu's dynamic you're sure to
enjoy this one after the mission while
the two are eating Q believe it or not
even cracks a smile although we only see
shinobu's reaction to it as Geo is
facing away from us shinobu comments
that she's never seen gyu smile before
the Side Story emphasizes how goo has
begun to change after his initial
encounter with tanjiro the rengoku
section is definitely the more exciting
one it follows kyojiro and Goku before
he was a hasha and before mitsuri
created love breathing and was still
trying to learn flame breathing from
kyojuro in this section it's explained
that to become a hasha you need to be a
kinoy ranked Corps member and defeat
either 50 demons or one of the 12 kizuki
demons AKA one of the 12 demon moons
kinoy is the highest rank before hashira
by the way before kinoy is kinoto then
hinoy hinoto
kanoe kanoto mizunoe and then the lowest
rank is mizunoto so there are 10 Rings
altogether not counting hashira but back
to rengoku in this Side Story his father
the current flame hashira has become a
poor excuse for hashira he drinks before
missions and on missions and doesn't
even bother to come when called after
his wife's death he doesn't see the
point of anything so Kyocera decides to
step up and take his place as flame
hashira in order to do so he defeats a
former lower Moon too with mitsuri's
help this lower moon is very unique in
that his Blood Demon Arc revolves around
shadows and Shadow wolves these Shadows
can suck in and store things like guns
or swords he often fights with the guns
rifles or even old school machine guns
he has stored within him and to make
matters worse he used time bombs too a
very tricky demon to be sure and you
really feel like kyojiro earned the
title of hashira when he overcomes this
demon Moon notably in both Kyu and
kyojoro's stories mitsuri is shown with
iguro so that's an Easter egg that
hardcore mitsuri and igoro shippers like
me will appreciate but seriously for
people like me who love it in Goku and
consider him to be one of my favorite
hush It Up This Side Story is an amazing
tribute to him and his hair character
fun anime outpro trivia fact that angoku
is on the only poster I have in my room
that's how much I respect the character
after these two longer Side Stories the
flame and water volume includes a sort
of manga summary of what happened in the
demonster anime so far but realism and
tension goes out the window for the sake
of Comedy for instance Kyu makes snowman
at an igloo while he waits for Tanja and
nazuko to wake up in the first episode
The Swamp demon obeys muzon so that
muzon won't spread the embarrassed
demons poetry around and so on and in
the volume afterward hirano does make it
clear that gotoge took time to check the
rough layouts and even made Corrections
when necessary so these guiyu and then
Goku Side Stories can be viewed as Canon
even if gotogay didn't draw them lastly
a special One-Shot Side Story was made
by gotage to Hype up the Mugen Train
movie again it dealt with rengoku who is
the Blazing star of the arc after all
again we have more kyotiro epicness here
the dude really never fails to impress
on his first ever Mission he overcomes a
tricky demon who uses hearing to
disorient demon Sayers by hitting his
own own ears so hard it ruptured his
eardrums then he proceeds to wreck the
demon to the demon shock cannot be said
enough this dude is such a legend and a
standout funny moment for me was when
the flu demon was disappearing as last
words were no I was going to join the 12
kizuki end quote layer 6. the Demon
Slayer mangaka released other manga
projects before demonster took off in
2016. the very first one from 2013 was
called kagarigari this one shot was a
sort of prototype for a Demon Slayer and
many ideas that would find their way
into demonster are included in this one
shot yoshiro and Tamayo are present so
is another character that dresses
similarly to muzon the demon antagonist
is eventually taken out by a human
swordsman who reminds me a bit of Gil
his family was killed by demons like
tanjiros and the Swordsmen even had to
go through his own file selection exam
he also lost an arm which might remind
you of how Tangen loses his arm or how
even tanjiro himself eventually loses
the use of his arm but despite the clear
similarities the mangaka definitely
changed a lot of things for the
demonstrator manga series including the
addition of main characters like Tanja
zaito and inosuke whom we love so much
however during the three years between
kagaragiri and kimetsunoyaiba koyoharu
also released a one shot called monju
Shiro kyodai in 2014
in 2014 as well and Hai niwa no zigzag
in 2015. these one shots were published
together as short stories by the manga
artist but unfortunately there hasn't
been an official English release yet
still from the images you can see how
some of these Works make their way into
demon Sarah as well like how the cover
character of mondru Shiro kyodai looks
very reminiscent to snake hasha
obanaiguro in rokotsu-san the story
follows a blind character who can see
the good and evil in people the idea is
reminiscent of the stonehashra gyome
lastly zigzag can be found translated
online and follows a character who
removes curses surprisingly the
protagonist is very different from the
kind-hearted and moral Tanja he actually
wanted to kill people through curses
before because he could make a lot of
money that way but then he got cursed
himself so that he could never kill or
use his power for personal gain he sort
of forced to be a good guy against his
will by the curse an interesting concept
and one very different from Tanja and
Demon Slayer unlike Tundra 2 zigzag's
protagonist punishes people who do bad
things and is described as a poison that
will eradicate evil lastly he uses
plant-based Powers which I found
interesting you can tell koyoharu is
into plan since we also have the blue
spider lilies and Demon Slayer that turn
muzon into a demon in the first place
layer 7 demonster has been censored and
I'm not talking about just calling the
red light district Arc the Entertainment
District Arc specifically China censored
the anime for instance in China tanjos
earrings are changed because they felt
like the earrings resembled the flag of
the Rising Sun too much which is
associated with Japanese imperialism
South Korea also censored the earrings
other censorship in China includes
covering up the chest area as seen with
tanks wives you can even find censored
images of doci wearing pants during her
fight against Tundra on the internet but
be careful because there are also fan
made images of fake censorship poking
fun at how China has censored the anime
layer 8. so we talked about what China
did to demon sir let's briefly discuss
what the internet did to Demon Slayer as
with many popular shows demos here has
given birth to multiple ongoing jokes
and countless memes I've been a fan of
the series for a long time and as a
result I have been exposed to a lot of
this some of the common jokes and or
memes poke fun at how zanitsu needs to
fall asleep to fight and sometimes on
how that hilariously backfired on enmu
who thought putting demon series to
sleep would make them powerless then
there is the similarities between
zenitsu and yutaro as they are both
jealous of Tangen having three wives
about how gyu has no friends about muzon
being Michael Jackson about how we must
all protect nezuko and of course we
can't forget tanjiro's memeable faces of
disgust and because of the lack of
actual romantic content in the manga elf
as you may guess people have created fan
fiction to fill in the details one such
fan fixture can be found on YouTube
depicting Tundra and kano's proposal and
it has 1.6 million views showing not
only how popular Demon Slayer is but
also how much more people want of these
characters as one top voted commenter
mentioned and I quote it's the part of
the manga that we never had but we
deserved end quote in the fan made
motion manga an older Tundra flips a
coin recalling to an earlier moment in
the series but this time replaces the
coin with a ring I appreciate their
General attention to detail and the
respect it pays to the history of the
story not to mention that it's super
sweet the only thing I will add is that
tanjur should technically not have
access to both hands and one of his eyes
should not work but aside from those
nitpicks it's great notably although
everyone loves the Kano and tanjura ship
the unrealized giu and shinobu ship is
one of the most popular ones among demon
Sarah fans the third light novel also
puts focus on the less known ship of
sanami and Kane shinobu's older sister
despite this ship being less talked
about in the fandom it actually has much
more of a basis in the story itself than
guio x shinobu for example in fact in
one of the official demonstrate fanbooks
that I mentioned there is a section
where the hashira state their
Impressions on the other hashira yomei
says the following about sanami he has a
strong spirit and is honest at heart he
likes Kanai and quote unfortunately the
fan books haven't gotten official
English releases yet either as far as I
can find but if you find full
translations or if they do get official
English releases after this video goes
up let us know in the comments on a side
note it's annoying how I can find all
these books translated in French on
Amazon and not in English why are the
French so ahead in anime appreciation I
don't know but the English-speaking
world has to pick up the slack layer 9.
for this one I'll mention some Demon
Slayer theories including some pretty
dark ones one not so dark one is that
dragon-shaped attacks are the strongest
not surprisingly dragons are associated
with power and even godliness in Japan I
don't think it's a coincidence that
kaido called the strongest creature in
the world has the oswar dragon fruit in
fellow Shonen Jump manga one piece
dragons are strong very strong and so
things associated with them are in turn
associated with this ultimate power thus
it's no coincidence that the first and
strongest breath style Sun breathing
even has a form called Dragon sun halo
head dance besides that we've seen
Tundras attacks take the form of a fiery
dragon as well notably though not every
breathing style takes the form of a
dragon however the 10th form of water
breathing and arguably the strongest
form called constant flux takes the form
of a water dragon the only one that
comes after is gyu's personally created
form but it's a defensive one rather
than an offensive one in addition to Sun
breathing and water breathing one of
zenitu's attacks also breaks all hype
limiters and takes the form of a dragon
it's specifically his already mentioned
personally invented seventh form called
honor kazuchi nokami AKA flaming Thunder
God it takes the form of a dragon-shaped
lightning bolt and is definitely the
strongest form of thunder breathing it
allows him to quickly take out his sword
of demon brother AKA demon Senpai
kaigaku without the demon enhanced
Thunder breath user even being able to
see what happened considering he's an
upper Moon and that the Thunder breath
users are especially fast even without
demon enhancements it's an insanely
impressive feat by zenitsu and it
further Hypes up dragon-shaped attacks
lastly this is not the case in the manga
interestingly enough but it is in the
anime flame pasta kyojiro and Goku's
strongest attack 9th form and then Goku
takes on the form of an epic flame
dragon in the movie notably iguro the
serpent hashira's attacks often take the
form of a snake or serpent but not of a
dragon it will be interesting to see if
the anime continues to add dragon-shaped
attacks not present in the manga as they
did with rengoku or if that was a
one-time change and I don't think it was
a coincidence that the three Styles
besides Sun breathing that took the form
of a dragon were part of the five main
breathing Styles which include Thunder
flame water stone and wind the thing
that makes these five special is that
they are only once removed from Sun
breathing the strongest in original
breathing style so although it was not
stated in black and white in the manga
it appears that these five along with
moon breathing should be considered
stronger in general than the other
breathing Styles which are more than
once removed from the strongest style
Sun breathing after all not all
breathing styles are created equal and
gotoge has made that clear in the manga
by consistently emphasizing that sun
breathing is the strongest thus
offshoots of offshoots of sun breathing
like flour and serpent breathing which
come from water breathing should be
considered weaker than the primary
offshoots that being said obviously the
skill of the user is important and igoro
as a serpent breather is way stronger
than murata as a water breather now
let's briefly go over how the breathing
styles are related since it's never
fully explained in the story Sun
breathing is obviously the original it
then breaks up into water Moon flame
Thunder Stone and Wind Flower and
serpent breathing come from water
breathing while inside like breathing is
the furthest of all breathing styles
from Sun breathing since it comes from
flower breathing and since I often rank
shinobu no matter how much I love her as
the weakest hashira this makes sense
love breathing comes from flame
breathing which goes well with that in
Goku's Side Story where we learned that
Mitri initially was learning flame
breathing sound breathing comes from
Thunder breathing and Beast and Mist
breathing come from when breathing that
gives us 14 confirmed breath Styles and
demons there however we saw two more
namely demon enhanced Thunder breathing
and Demon enhanced Moon breathing while
it's been confirmed that the elemental
effects we see the demon Slayers using
aren't actually real the demon enhanced
versions do actually use the element in
question in their attacks for instance
kaigaku actually creates lightning that
burns zanito's flesh with these two
demon enhanced Styles you can say there
are 16 rather than 14 confirmed breath
Styles while in theory there could be up
to 28 when counting each style and its
demon alternative but even this number
is not definitive since if the world of
demon Sarah were to to go on and new
demons were to appear it's possible that
new breath Styles would be invented just
like shinobu invented insect breathing
beats reinvented love breathing and
inosuke invented Beast breathing now
let's discuss why Tundra sword is black
the easiest way to explain it is because
he is a sunbreather and the first breath
style user yorichi also had a Black
Blade that turned red when used in
battle what people may not have noticed
is that this goes very well with
Tundra's Origins Tundra was a coal
burner coal is also black until you burn
it the sword turning red has also been
associated with heat and Tundra even had
to use nesco's Flames to turn it red for
a while so really even aside from being
a sunbreather thing it goes perfectly
with Tanja on his background makes us as
a coal burning family they would be sun
breathers another unique aspect to
Demon's air are the Demon's air marks
the Demon's air marks are like going
Super Saiyan for demon Slayers they
become faster and stronger but it comes
at a cost a severe cost the curse of the
mark means that demon Sailors who awaken
the mark die before reaching the age of
25 AI That's What upper Moon 1 kokushibo
tells us this puts a dark spin on the
end of Demon Slayer because it means
that people who awaken the mark But
survived the final battle like tanjiro
Gio and sanami only have until 25 to
live considering that so many people
died already that's a hard pill to
swallow even if tanjiro did have about
another decade to live and even had kids
however their deaths at 25 haven't been
confirmed and perhaps we could come to
the conclusion that since the demons
were defeated then the curse has been
lifted and even if it weren't yorichi as
kokushibo explains was an exception and
lived on well past 25 even though he had
the mark perhaps it's wishful thinking
but if yorichi could do it perhaps
fellow sunbreather and yorichi successor
tanjiro could also overcome the curse
but if we just follow how curses usually
work that is a very dark Theory indeed
to assume that Tundra can't live past
25. another theory to consider is that
the demon threat may not be over and
this could be the case for variety of
reasons even in the modern day yoshiro
is still alive painting pictures of
Tamayo this suggests that there could be
other demons too that survived out there
even after Busan was killed then there's
the fact that muzon wasn't a demon until
a doctor somehow turned him into one
using the blue Spider Lily thus there's
no guarantee that another doctor will
make the same mistake and turn someone
else into a demon and the other thing to
consider is is muzon and or his
influence Gone Forever After all we saw
him inject his blood into tanjiro and we
saw him even manifest himself inside of
tanjiro so it could be possible that he
could manifest himself inside of tundra
again granted since the future is at
peace it looks like there weren't any
issues and that Tundra lived happily
ever after but considering how quickly
Tundra went from Demon King Tundra to
human again one wonders if the
possibility remains for him to access
those demon powers again at some point
in addition to the medicine tanja's
belief in his friends who were waiting
for him helped him reject muson's
influence so one wonders if something
happened to trigger him like the death
of his loved ones could it cause him to
snap and awaken that influence within
him again the implications of demon king
tanjiro would also be insane which is
why in all honesty this would probably
never happen the story didn't cover it
but if Tundra passed through his berserk
mode he could have eventually become
like higaku and kokushibu in other words
he could have become a demon enhanced
Sun breather that would make him
unbeatable because as suggest in the
series he like muzon could overcome
beheading And he as a sun-breathing
demon was immune to the Sun and thus to
nitrine blades which get their power
from the Sun muzon succeeded in creating
the perfect unbeatable demon so much so
that the only way to stop Demon King
Tundra was through the power of
friendship before he ever got strong
enough to use Sun breathing
swordsmanship as a demon another theory
or you might say argument that I want to
bring up is that demiser is an
anti-shonen i outlined this in more
detail in my the controversial
philosophy of demons her video but the
main idea is that a lot of Shonen tend
to have characters who strive to be the
best they prioritize this goal Luffy
wants to be pirate king in one piece
Naruto wants to be Hokage and Naruto
Deku wants to be the greatest hero in
mha also wants to be the wizard King in
Black Clover and so on and so on Shonen
obviously is just referring to a
demographic but it can't be denied that
Shonen often follow this formula in
stark contrast to this Tanja doesn't
want to be the strongest Demon Slayer
rather he wants to save his sister and
go back to living a peaceful and by Sean
standards on eventful life in fact the
guy who wanted to be the strongest
desperately was upper Moon one kokushibu
and his life turned out horribly because
of that unquenchable desire so it's
interesting to look at demonstrator
through this lens as it subverts common
Shonen ideas and asks us to reassess
what's actually most important in life
and just to make things clear this isn't
good or bad per se it's just different
and I appreciate that about Demon Slayer
and that is the Demon's air Iceberg
smash that like button if you appreciate
this video which will no doubt turn out
to be a long one that required a bunch
of work and research like I said if you
learned something new it would really be
appreciated if you smash that like
button and subscribe and if you like
this you shouldn't miss our every upper
Moon's backstory video where we go in
depth into the fascinating and sometimes
shocking backstories of each upper Moon
where we give each story more Justice
than I could do in this video link on
screen right now and in the description